IT'S FELT LIKE AN ETERNITY TO
RETURN BACK TO HOCKEY H A
TURNOVER, BUT THE PUCK FINDS
BRELT RICHIE.
HE, JORDAN STALL,
CALGARY MAKES ANOTHER GOO A CLOE
R
WITH REGULARITY FOR CAROLINA.
>> Mike:
FRONT, BUT ANDERSON HOLDS THE
LINE.
FACEOFF NOW TO THE LEFT OF THE Y
WITH IT.
BACKLUND INTO THE CANNG THE FASE
PUCK, AND HE'LL RIFLE CANES GET.
FAST TO SVECHNIKOV.
UP TOP
FIRST PERIOD
HIM.
HE'S GOT CLEAR.
HE'LL GET SOME HELP FROM
BACKLUND
BACK TO COLE.
AND HE'LL THE BOARD HERE IN
RALEIGH FINDS ITS WAY BACK FROM
THEE OFF ATE FIRST PERIOD, THEYE
CRANKED IT UPAYERS IN THESE, IT.
AHO JUST ABOUT THAT
ANDERSEN HAD 4-2OUND THE BOARDSF
JEANETTE WELL KNOW THE END OF
THAT TRIUMPHANT SEVEN-GAME
SERIES.
>> MIKE: COULD NOT DRAFTED IN 2
HE WILL GIVE THE AND THEN
KOTKANIEMI.  NT GOALS.
>> NOT JUST RELYING ON OF GOALS
NOT MANY SLAPPERS.
HE WAS